hey hey oh [ __ ] I don't have also an I
can't be doing that what's happening is
Hannibal what's going on thank you for
listening to the podcast I usually don't
do intros but I'm bored on a trailer and
micromanaging and delaying the edit we
had a good time
Tony trim on the beat and stuff we've
been having a lot of fun making music
talking [ __ ] thank you guys for
listening and indulging us Brian Babylon
is also in this episode and when I guess
Tiffany Haddish who is outstanding one
of my favorite people in will hilarious
catch her in the new girl strip movie
coming out
I think July 21st she's on the
Carmichael show on NBC and she had her
own special coming out she ready
on Showtime so it's a fun episode we
talk [ __ ] check us out we gonna be a FYF
fest in July and probably roaming around
somewhere I hope you good is the episode
[Music]
on another episode in of the handsome
Rambo podcast with la co-host Tony trim
so good friend funny comedian prime
Babylon in the building and a special
guest hilarious Tiffany Haddish hottie
huh
was that beep everybody ready ready knee
came up in here with an avocado and a
gallon of water healthy my treatment I
just egged some Popeyes Chicken on the
way here so I got a counter five pounds
there's one on the bread and a Jefferson
you know what there's one on Western a
Martin Luther King's Hollywood Boulevard
one mm-hmm
you know what I ask somebody for Orson
fried fish was kinda anchoring for some
fryer perch I'm from Chicago and these
people look at me like I was speaking
French oh the best part fish in the city
is Mel's fish shack right their own farm
bill in Jefferson you know Monday's we
have a crab soup is fine it's becoming a
gentrified neighborhood it's right next
to Dorsey high school also but it's you
know it used to be predominantly black
and Asian now it's like Hispanic people
don't run like yes they do
you just don't be in the right part of
town oh yeah you gotta be electrolyte
was it Allah Allah alkaline alkaline
water and I wrote all over the Juke to
program my water yeah yeah cuz right on
the judge I wrote millionaire she ready
happy success and that was my body
success water she ready success what you
just see it all the time and that's good
to see
mm-hmm and the water Giving Program
because water see you too it's that dr.
nakamora a water experiment you know I'm
kind of knowledgeable yeah you got that
from from that that movie right what was
it I got really what the blue you ever
see what the bleep do you know I found
on YouTube man how many people doing the
experiment on YouTube yeah well right
right it's not like a vision board but
it's on water people well they say you
know they say that if you put the energy
into like whatever your water or
whatever it'll it'll happen it's just
like you know yeah but if I'm like I'm
gonna be a millionaire by the end of the
year and I will be happy with success
and I'm gonna be ready well I'm already
ready but continue to be ready how many
gallons do you think you need I drink a
gallon a day that's what you mean when
did you start drinking a gallon a day I
started it when I got back from doing a
girls trip back in a September yeah okay
September so you've been in the gallon a
day for about nine months
yeah yeah hmm I came down to New Orleans
and kicked it with you well you all my
guys trip yes it was a fun time yeah we
had a blast
fun time we went to uh you invited us to
clean the people's house yeah I was like
clear you're not bring my friend she was
like they got something to lose okay
nobody come in my house unless they got
something to lose and I was like well
they entertainers I think maybe she's
like what in here they can come as long
as I got something to lose and then real
yeah I haven't taken that philosophy now
after I got robbed yeah yeah oh yeah
right mm-hmm
by who by a family member you know
exactly little I don't know exactly who
it was but it police gonna find out
because we got fingerprints and
everything she was a family it was a
family only function yeah I left my let
a couple of family members stay at my
house oh they went so whoever was went
digging in my class all know and they
stole my piggy bank they stole all the
money on my bank and just left one penny
in each one oh that's just petty and
they took them sighs change loose change
it was loose changing it but also I was
dropping like hundred dollar bills and
fifty dollar bills every time I got paid
like cash for show I would drop you know
if you heard him it was like two g's or
more that's that's upset it it is
devastating as you gave them a gift of
living in your home we mm-hmm thank you
does do they dust they test it so how
they dusted my wig box because it was
inside my wig box underneath wigs so are
you gonna invite your family back over
you give me something to drink and I
take all those glasses yeah you know
that
you know yeah I put in a little
heaviness bag yeah but it will name
cousin tree like that same from Martin
well first on two of them already have
records so they already they
fingerprints in a database already mm
great strikes they got uh 100 yeah I'm
on each yeah I'm the man whether this
happen this happen between it had to
happen between Christmas yeah and a
March so if it turns out to be a close
family member are you gonna press
charges
yeah yeah okay I'm not the [ __ ] year
sucks
okay what what I did was I went to
youtube and I started looking at curses
and I put a curse on whoever took so
like it's gonna be all that ended okay
let's go and then I have programs from
water to make me more powerful we're
going to make the curse accident so I do
I want to [ __ ] with you in your corner
magical creature
what's this curse one-time thing do you
have to keep on is it like your water
ritual where it's a daily thing I took
it at one time I don't have time to keep
doing that [ __ ] over and over so if
you're a full time which I'm not a full
time with what well it was it was like
one incantation they like one thing and
they like spin around it
well know what I did was I have wrote on
a bottle of water you know
Tiffany is the most powerful unicorn in
the universe true then I have put my
hands on both the banks and put all my
energy into the back look right and then
I started to you know make a cursor yeah
and I have prayed for God to give me the
power to activate that country in that I
don't necessarily want revenge
I just want reparations my god I'm on
board with this
give me mix God up with witchcraft no
bro but I don't use me I didn't feel
like I personally I don't feel like it's
witchcraft I feel like I'm using my
powers my power of will
yes we all have that and you know you
can you're doing this justice all that
crime yeah well you know I feel like
this anybody do something bad to me and
need to come back on them times ten
straight up
I mean old-school God was
uh more about smiting [ __ ] and
he was yeah oh you hope oh my god who
sits on here what the [ __ ] out of y'all
yeah yeah but uh yeah bugs really lucky
locusts for ya measles will embers yeah
oh Jesus came to was I turn the other
cheek bro yeah but still but jesus said
jesus said let my father get to befriend
my father will take care of the revenge
you don't have yeah you turn the other
cheek pray to the Lord put it on him
yeah and that's that so that's basically
what I did
I mean I kind of saw people running that
tables you know what I'm saying at one
time it Blair won that one time I was
out here all with a posse so he had to
do next I ended up getting mercs oh
thank that was for us down here half a
day marketing ball so he could have been
like deuces if the loaded up out of
there it's true Jesus reminds me one of
them dudes you see living in Venice like
what is the most relaxed white dude you
know mm-hmm just real chill you know
yeah fuzzy but might have a Rich Dad yep
yep trust fund baby yeah yeah definitely
my baby do magic on the side he got his
home back people you know hear anything
they've had a thievery situation but it
wasn't with a family member where I rent
out a spot on Airbnb mm-hm and I have
property manager need somebody had a
catfish account where they made it look
like they were a white lady from Iowa
and they were actually people from
Chicago and they stole like two pieces
of art
bunch of other [ __ ] it's a being several
thousand dollars in the [ __ ] and then I
found out and all the people who were
there but I got my money reimbursed but
I just let it go
really yeah cuz I got my money
reimbursed like that's the Francesco it
is so the cursed thing I'm into
yeah well if you want I can help show
you how to do it yes so we got cars and
I'm gonna go touch the walls where they
took that art
and say God smite these fools and if
they ride bicycles make the wheels fall
off and if they drive cars make them
explode on highway make the engine lock
that's the words like I put oil in this
nitrogen are exploitable tires left or
let what happened to you happened to
them times T yeah times 10 look good at
you hmm you don't mean that hold on to
next mm-hmm you said you got this spell
on YouTube what is technique
is it like a person like hey alright
just week I got this revenge spell or
this love spell not is it's a you know
how to how to curse somebody oh yeah
and a spell it's a curse you could call
somebody which is your words and your
emotions right here's what I think even
if your results of the curse don't work
I think it's still kind of therapeutic
problem yeah it feels like I was able to
get over like I'm kind of for the moment
I'm still like I I'm over it for the
most part I'm not like mad no more or
whatever and it's so funny because of my
ass God - like what you know whatever
happens for the person let's it let me
find out about it so out of the out of
the four potential people it could have
been I've been hearing some crazy so
they lies they messed up something I
sort of think you know that maybe they
all took some of the money
oh they might say how much you got how
heist well I'm not sure but I just know
everybody [ __ ] messed up it's my stuff
sorry are you their famous cousin we're
like you know him and she's doing her
she ain't girls he gonna be i MMA
fighter like me and I'ma just leave a
penny cuz she don't need this money
which you know I mean all my mind you do
I mean every single dime I was used
saving the money up to like if I had
some things going on with my car
whatever I could just use cash and
getting a car together or whatever and
so I was getting some body work done on
my car let me just go on and get the
money out there it was empty just a
penny in each one I felt like somebody
socked me in the chest
yeah being a unicorn ain't she the penny
thing though that's the strangely
that's messed up right in three weird
one of the one of the members one of the
members was a child with the 12 year old
so I really in my heart because I
remember when I was 12 I used to sell
out of piggy banks yeah you know yeah
actually I just got my license but to
let me hold my breath rate maybe just
coming back on me you know a 12 year old
with thousands of dollars but this 12
year old is like one of them that try to
be like popular with other kids and
stuff so I could imagine them you know
buying everybody merged you know candy
for everybody
Oh y'all want you want some boy she
might like like you know she likes that
sucker this [ __ ] and you might try to
fire your gangs well boy or whatever you
know the mentality of leaving a penny
though like what what what's the motive
you know what is that that's not behind
that I mean as some jealousy some
jealousy pettiness hatred you think you
better than us [ __ ] you take care of my
two cents mm-hmm and he left to pick one
it was to piggy banks in there it was
three total but they only got into and
they just left and one teeny in each
Bank
so that's see I like Hannibal's theory I
don't know that what is yeah that's what
I felt
here's my two cents yeah did you call
that girl trip trailer and I didn't you
know I told you when I saw the girl trip
trailer and I was excited I was the last
trailer to come on
when I saw get up and you killed it in
the trailer it was just you it was your
trailer and you uh
what was the line you can't um you can't
get an infection in your booty how
anyhow and then it was some it was some
way dude in the bro in front of me after
the trailer went off he was like bully
ha
they were some white Hollywood exec in
that like ya trailer Hills that was cool
I'm pretty sure gay men love that
statement 50 bully oh yeah
no in fact a video so you are you ready
to be a movie star
uh yeah I've been ready she's ready
look at her water bottle yeah success
water that part so it might she might be
working well this water might be real
I won't stop sucking with that success
water yeah what you want to have i've
already patented you want your beats to
be and advertising him I want well I'm a
bump J to rap on my Beach TJ guys good
jail got him out her he thought I saw
somebody I took a you know the Chicago
rapper bum Jay was in jail flip yeah he
had a buzz we had the big song move
around
remember that move around right move
around okay and he I think Kanye
produced decks I was Kanye big four
years ago it was a minute ago and he
went to jail for why he just got out and
then somebody had linked to his
Instagram and it said you know for
booking email this and for beats beats
for bum Jake I like this could be you
saw some Beast of Bugsy get the bump
Jake placements ahead yep let's turn him
right back I need some beats gonna be
yeah I got genes I'm trying to come out
with a little you know she ready album
yo go this is great because podcast is a
surgical network is yeah would be we are
the industry we just need this podcast
to facilitate people's needs it snapped
I know I'm all to be temples on the
theremin come on those Airmen that there
means
Behrman baby oh yeah the curse word
unlike Artemis II but my love but that
die my love I would take my painting you
know we don't worry comment whatsoever
still will sol-gel piggy bank that that
just plays in our brain yeah
forever Hannibal theremin music hmm and
they just walk on it's noise in my head
that would be great I'll be granted more
sirs you know don't worry messed up
though I have foreign money in here you
know oh yes of your life I have with the
title and fight some Thai Baht some they
took the board money too that's rich
Canadian money on it took all of that oh
it was just a various weird-ass amount
you don't really know what it was I know
it was more than two thousand dollars
but yeah is there like a Big Mama and
the family that you can go report this
to they can get everybody to like Big
Mama he stole my money all hold on let
me call somebody I know who did it and
she can get to the bottom of this I mean
my granny but Ashish she don't get
involved and stuff like that she'd be
like well you shouldn't have let that
raggedy [ __ ] my house anyway
ain't had none to lose I'm like good
time at that party it was very many was
off the chain it was a realtor this is
that Queen Latifah's house in New
Orleans on 4th of July yes right now she
was renting a house from Sandra Bullock
oh really we was in Sandra Bullock
bullets beautiful crib where it were
part-time and I forget where in New
Orleans I guess uptown or like that
gardening Garden District made me
beautiful crib
who else was there oh my god everybody
Jada Pinkett was there the rents tight
in the bride and his brothers marriage
April birthday blige was there too
different I don't think she was dancing
she was just she knew who I was it threw
me off what
between July like nice to meet you I'm
analyst I know you are
Michael [ __ ] I'm gonna head to the funny
of a marriage I was going through a
breakup and I was I was with Dianna
essence festival that's off mary j blige
know after that the minute
Mercedes don't know what I want yet but
we were downstairs and she had this
performance she was on a golf cart and
she's like how you doing I don't know
man I'm drunk
you're not get real friendly and talk
about the MRI want to break up
there's a baby listen the people you
would now may not be the people you wit
at the end of your journey
mmm angel off no golf car oh my god
paper hat I heard two c's really uh just
nice and warm like the average top story
on Twitter where a woman was sitting
next to her on the on the plane and the
plane had turbulence and and mary j
blige just grabbed her hand and said you
know don't let fear take over just
prayed with her I believe that yeah I
sorta got a real love man she do she's I
feel like a realized she looked you in
your eyeballs these people look at you
to compare late nothing I was looking at
your forehead is like [ __ ] it she look
at me my eyes and told me that I might
well God a marriage a blacks thank you I
won't be okay I was acting [ __ ]
because I got all excited I like kind of
fangirl doubt I was drunk affair like
this and I was talking to Larissa I to
his brother I was been in the pool I had
my little drink and then I heard her
voice I look back and I was like yeah is
that mary j blige and it was like yeah I
was like I'll be right back and I like
backstroke over here I love you music me
and my friends bumpin your music oh we
was a high schooler stuff and but we was
riding around in a Pontiac killing me
is it I had gone out the pool and I was
bloated I thought at least I felt
bloated because I was drunk and so my
swimmers who had gathered up in my ass
and everything and I was pulling it out
and she was looking at me and I thought
a girl I just got a modeling contract
with big life my regular body addition
this is he's aware the the baseball hat
with the we poor people cutting holes
baseball had to put your ponytail yeah
yeah she did that that's created with
the baseball jersey and uh the little
short with boots real look she was icon
and she is Ike I mean like she was on
every hot hook back then every hot rap
hook I mean she had always [ __ ] but it
that song came together when she sang on
your hook automatic hit so do you think
she's the original like around the way
girl like you don't say like hey
everybody got to Mary Jane in the
neighborhood like every go to every
neighborhood there's like a Mary j-style
keep it real cheap mmm
it depend on what hood you go through
I've been through a lot of neighborhood
it's where your buddy were you from
South Central LA oh okay the real [ __ ]
yeah and I grew up in foster care so I
lived in a lot of different places in
their fun neighborhoods on hand Oh Mary
Jane people they got in there like
staying in Woodland Hills main Oh Mary
Jane you got there was this woman is
right that's white people man but now
you know it's getting gentrified too now
but back when I would lux yeah with
blacks and Hispanics and her little
Easton's in agents and stuff like that
but when I was in school you know I was
going to school over in that area it was
only 3% black in my high school
so yeah whatever hood is a King Kong
ain't got nothing on that's what jungles
that's right down away from my house and
it's changed it's so different now in
anything like now you could drive around
two o'clock in the morning and don't
have to worry about nobody shooting at
your car and you can see - you know I've
seen the other day I've seen - gate
white man holding hands and kissing I
was like up it's different now is that
what I got shot through biggest on
reaching for each other hand we keep
that specific shot back in 95 Hey that I
will be and the public's would've been
like they send Ben over here they know
better
[ __ ] should've nobody gonna come over
here oh man expressing yells oh yeah you
don't express okay and do that 95 so now
it's like Starbucks and barriers of
Starbucks down the street and and they
redoing the whole Crenshaw mall I'm
super excited because you know my house
is like down the street from there and
you know when they redo stuff like that
is just
oh they bring the train system in
property but you know going up my should
already went up by 100,000 like a real
billionaire when you bring a train in
when you bring the generator and they
building a five-star hotel on Crenshaw
like it's finished in a racking you
bother get some money they got to put a
kaiser permanente over there now never
where there have been a Kaiser
Permanente what is that like I knew what
the [ __ ] is like the hospital yeah Oh
Kaiser Permanente Medical Center right
they're like okay yes I know is why
people moving in I get a fine car Kaiser
Permanente yeah yes I thought it was an
explosive pots place Corinthian leather
seats just the slaughtering and the
Compton I mean like what used to be I
think there's one in Montebello too but
at its Lawson they tried they change the
name to the super-marv
you know because it's becoming
gentrified so well why people don't go
to swap me I don't want those what
explains what meat so people listening
so they ought to Google why they listen
it okay if you've ever been to a flea
market
that's what meat is very similar to that
it's just you know where you go and you
can barter it maybe you know talk
somebody down but you can't even do that
anymore at the slots in the back of the
day can be like let me get you know 20
pair of socks for $7.00 they'd be like
no no you pay for anything like look
okay throw in a pair of shorts and I'll
pay 10 you know get a flavor it's a yeah
but you said barter like you can you
trade can you walk them be like here's
some weed let me get I don't think I
don't think maybe if you got some kimchi
or something like that
because it's predominantly Korean I'm
pretty sure we okay no matter all they
are great they're like getting drugs
away from me and that's in Chicago we
had a this change back in they called a
Jew town back everybody yeah you get a
jew town publishers compos get your
ginger the Jew town and then I guess I
was like not right to say no more than I
changed it to next little Maxwell Street
no you still they call it use you City
no or something like that it's changed
magnetic yes max I'm in love Chicago is
or was very racist is it here other
somewhere do tab yeah I guess so
Koreatown is every race almost had
neighborhood in the way Chicago is
talked me we still use slang from that's
not acceptable anymore and people just
urgently he's long squeeze old school
knows I'm so wicked I don't got a
question yeah now if you have a certain
age did you from Chicago yeah I've
always heard people say all man you gay
and they not talking about someone's
sexual products but they become are John
Wayne Gacy no perfect the day you call
people gay sees I'm a you okay to get
away from me mouth yeah Casey he was he
was the he was the serial killer yeah
what she always say in different ways
that we say like North Side say hey guys
he's acting like a gay right a gay right
or gay but it was always off of John
Wayne Gacy
I didn't know that yeah give a call
people gay fees they see remember when I
used a copy for Fugazi that's Italian
loan [ __ ] for gays for gays money
laughing jay-z when I'm I promote
something from I think he said that in a
song it's Fugazi
I've got 996
Oh mojo you crazy you can gave me a logo
with no Papa hate it yeah cuz they ride
somebody it's gonna tell you it baby you
know is that what does that mean Oh like
veiny nose of Moses it's a fund yeah
it's a Fugazi is fake
yeah it's also gave the ass up out of
here yeah that's yes how I know it like
what Michael California chick dissing
some dude sorry number two Fugazi so
what was like growing up in uh central
south central mouth sancho that was whoo
it was fun it was so adventurous oh my
god I got to meet so many clothes or
colors pants but I think I had killer
today was a good day I think about that
song mm-hmm lead accurate was an
accurate depiction it's pretty accurate
yeah yeah it's pretty accurate
cuz you grew up in the in the and the
height of it mm mm and height of the
chronic in yeah and I don't worry gang
wars and : all that Solis against
everybody just like now boy works do
people still get caught up in like red
and blue mm-hmm still get caught up in
it still like not in Hollywood mm not so
much in Hollywood but thank you might
get banged on in Hollywood if some
crazy-ass gangster comes on the other
side of Wilshire do I have a pair of red
Adidas and Michael like [ __ ] were done
player Mike what is he saying like oh
yeah that could be a problem
it just it depends you know what I
always thought growing up was crazy
about South Central LA is like because
in Chicago when you see the hood it
looks like the hood shits fall apart
[ __ ] up buildings but South Central LA
looks like a nice isn't it looks
beautiful eyes you a nice laws nice
cribs I've always this crime here what's
goin how you how you so decide you got
three [ __ ] why you shoot each
other so nice but it's like territory
and just money and yeah [ __ ] like that
who's in [ __ ] it's mostly alpha
[ __ ] yeah yeah well does I in history
in general look is getting killed little
bull the drug game look at the hair on
of the crack was crack crack crack crack
crack crack crack
I had auntie that was on crack she got
shot in the back by her drug dealer
oh my stop doing yet she stopped doing
crack one of the saddest I reserved this
drug dealer wanted he wanted her to be
his girl and she was like I'm not about
that life no more we should be cool but
I am [ __ ] what you like that and so
when she had walked out the house he
basically shot her in the back what he's
like Oh weird I'd like maybe four hours
later she was crazy as hell right was
nothing like the correct mm-hmm
was he crazy before the correct she was
a little off ever since she had got some
dental work done I gave her that
laughing cast off and then after that it
was over and so my grandma I don't never
get no laughing gas when you getting
your teeth done if something take it to
the end you won't be a crackhead do that
laughing gas
so was uh working on girl [ __ ] was up
first time in New Orleans not I was like
my third I was like my fourth time
working there yeah been there quite a
few times neither for two months though
two and a half months yeah yeah so uh
how I was yeah I think every major movie
I've been in was shot in New Orleans oh
yeah Tiana sod New Orleans own shot in
New Orleans meet the Spartans was shot
in New Orleans race up the time which
was the Lifetime movie that idea where I
was a drug addict and not a very good
job I was so skinny races the time I
gotta check the whole day with Charles
has been a yeah I got Acosta if you like
he oh yeah mm-hmm
yeah we're kind of I mean what was your
what was your motivation for getting to
that drug place I'm not just you know do
some character work you know wrote about
my character then I went to hang out
with a few people that I know is strung
out and watch them for a minute once I'm
real serious because it's interesting to
see your process because mine is uh just
reading words you wrote about your
character I wrote about it like my bid
like a diary like as if I was heard you
know uh but you're originally a stand-up
right yeah born and raised and uh and
then and then you crossed over yeah but
you know what before I started doing
stand-up I was in drama festivals doing
monologues and stuff like that and I was
winning like first place on all of them
like an experience of Lourdes yeah you
know modern festivals whatever from high
school so there and I was getting in
trouble a lot so my social worker made
me go through the last factory comedy
camp
yeah and that's how I got into stand-up
I got moldy god-shaped but I always had
to get yeah what you good you never took
classes though you just naturally I am
working classes yeah I took I can call a
I want ahead an investment in my future
we're going to technique that diary
technique
um you made that up or you know I have
watched some actor I can't remember who
it was after sushi Actors Studio thing
and they was talking about how they
write about their character so I figure
I'll just make a diary of my character
you never do and in that way like I can
just really be living that life like
that character's life because that's
what you could train somebody's slice of
life yeah that which I learned from
Margie Hebert that you got to be you
know when you're acting you're acting
out somebody's existence yeah so you
want to be in that mode you want to be
thinking like that character and all
that so so tight like dear diary this
correct wasn't [ __ ] today well I was
like dear diary my mama beat me my daddy
stole all my money on my piggy bank so I
just go do drugs my friend she offered
me some and I tried it and I liked it do
you think roundcube mmm I was right
about us just about that you could how
how how what do you do if I can't do I
want to do that to fool people
I just think about [ __ ] that hurts and
it just it just comes naturally yeah I
guess I can see here and cries he wanted
me to it's not gonna come out I don't
want to eat my [ __ ] it's gonna be crazy
oh [ __ ] I got like a crying [ __ ] I'm
doing
what happens to me when I cried lay down
lay down
[ __ ] you'd be crying around I
mean how we handle it around with me
will you look or in like that around
here
hahahahaha playboy stars car you don't
come all tears back in you hands on the
car
sorry oh hey that's your song guys I'm
in a real that is me better oh my
maternal trick put those clouds back in
you put the keys back in your eyes back
in Vega are be hit uh yeah watch you got
knowledge you got that recorded I got
that the Facebook's but you forgot to
offer the head though and maybe next
time yeah you got in that right away
seems manipulative yeah yeah something
like a little cry music for this is
filled hey don't think I kind of like a
wet one second okay I wouldn't take
advantage of your weak moment like that
even and I said may even if you were
trying to manipulate me by fake crying I
wouldn't fall like that so we kind of I
try to calm you down and you be at a
standstill just watch TV is on but
grieving women make me nervous
really yeah a little nervous when a
woman's just starts crying in front of
me i legit get like an anxiety attack
why that's how I am with babies to I
just kind of pat him on the handle like
cuz you know what I do yeah if it wasn't
if it was their fault someone who
started crying like
it was my mom just like yeah it frees up
my fault like okay I know I did let me
but this is you crying about something
to happen to you early today like [ __ ]
oh but even there it's funny one time I
was in Miami and I was walking down the
street and then I just start breaking
down tears to start crying like hard it
feels not everything and it's all like
but yes you walk to he's like what you
crying for I said I don't know I don't
even know how crazy it is like you want
a hug that I was like never mind no like
you need to stop crying there just
that's a [ __ ] up Miami yeah my noble
looks hopeful hugs will make you feel
back now that shirt is ruined present
yeah then you got bedbugs yeah right
yeah Frandsen and I'm Jimmy I'm
interested in your that the active
process so how long were you right as
the character um until I start shooting
so from when you get the when you get
the book the role till you start shoot
you right as that character mm-hmm I try
to do at least a paragraph or two a day
men that's very focused yeah no no I'm
not success yeah hey like I'm trying to
I'm gonna have to eat gas one day Oh
Emmy Grammy Tony mm-hmm Oscar mmm-hmm
egg two as Babylon likes to go yeah okay
[Music]
so you got a you diary as a character
and there was the what's the other part
and then I make sure I know my lines I
try to make sure I know all my lines and
then I just go for it
meet up with and when you know when I
meet with wardrobe or whatever if I
could have any same what I wear I try to
you know think as how to character who
want a dress how they want to be yeah
and then just go for it
let me ask you this when you memorize
your lines that's how the writer wrote
it right you have like okay I get it the
way you want to but I have like one or
two different little I always have like
alternates and my buttons and tags and
punchlines and stuff that I like in
girls trips they like I was I felt what
I just I saw and I felt like they use
like 75% of my like adlet result which I
had already been like writing so you
already seen it my bark of a good actor
and here goes the thing I never lasted
myself when I watch myself I don't
really laugh I just got a hilarious okay
that's bad I'll show you that's what's
up and when I saw it I remember that
first like the first three minutes I was
just like I don't like this care don't
even like this [ __ ] like that means I
did a good job I didn't like me really
and then I started growing on me that
kept my character started to grow on me
then I was like yeah I'm like rooting
for and like want to do whatever she
want to do and then I was laughing I was
like genuinely laughing out loud and
then there's this one thing that there's
a grapefruit involved and I freakin
laugh so hard I peed on myself and I
don't feel myself
trips or full-on like not for long pee
it was like like like Oh something came
out yeah like oh holy I gotta go to the
bathroom real quick or just about
everything like like I ain't never had
no kids and I'm like that you know I
don't know dude I don't know if guys had
this but you laugh so hard you get like
you feel a little bit mmm I just got too
far to go yeah football's maybe for you
maybe you have a big penis I gotta do my
damn it Brian while you was trying to go
yeah well let me tell you is it for me a
bit down there text me at least a minute
before I need to hit it so you're like
what out honestly
but I saw the trailer in the theater saw
the trailers and friends I'll say your
likability um radar or a meter was like
off the charts
I'm all for those you know ladies like I
like that one
who's the other ladies Queen Latifah
Jada pinkett-smith and Regina Hall Oh
who's Regina Hall who is Regina I don't
have help me out Gary movie Think Like a
Man got it got it got it
our cast right there okay um it was uh
yes I'm excited to see that a lot and
and I think the vibe people get from you
on stage and on camera in real life is
that you just give off this good energy
i people want to be your friend like
we were at that party at uh claims he
was house within about twenty thirty
minutes of being there you were holding
court with everybody like telling
stories remember you exist I think we
left you about five minutes of some
denied I stepped outside and it was just
and users teacher somebody who's like
and then that's how you roll a joint
there's like three people around this
enraptured and super centers you
facilitator but yeah I'm a teacher
Nexus [ __ ] was happen it I get my snacks
the [ __ ] you knows how to lips smack the
[ __ ] you know what happened it I get my
snacks issues you know what happened it
was Maxis shoot you knows how to get the
late spot you know about get young ships
in the techno pack just get the [ __ ]
box
you know what that let's get some
flowers please
is that your happening get gamma snack
[ __ ] get 7x5 get get a snack [ __ ] get
detonate by get get a snack [ __ ] snowing
happening get that [ __ ] dep depilated
baba this episode of the handsome
Rambler is brought to you by naturebox
eating better is hard especially when
you like snacks naturebox can help you
with that they have over a hundred
snacks that taste good and I actually
better for you they're made from
high-quality simple ingredients which
means no artificial colors flavors or
sweeteners another that [ __ ] so you
can feel good about what you eating
there's ever a snag you don't like that
would place it for free they sent over
some snacks to me I tried out their
sweet jalapeno juice and uh the sriracha
cashews fire so for handsome rambling
fans naturebox is offering three free
snacks with your first order
when you go to naturebox calm
/ Rambler that's naturebox.com/tyler
Ambler and you get three free snacks
with your first order don't sleep with
this we with Coachella mm-hmm we went to
it was a Drake's party red robot told us
midnight and so I'm thinkin NASA is I
was thinking maybe use performing going
it started at midnight and so we got
there we were at midnight just thinking
cuz it was a Sunday like Oh Sunday at
midnight citizen we are running going we
got there they weren't even serving
drinks yet got you're thirsty earlier
yeah it was waiting this weird alien it
was a bad like drink fanboys and like
everything by you I was terrible but the
house was like so weirdly situated they
didn't know like bar to go to really
quick it was just it would have been out
of the way to leave and come back so we
just Hannibal we're Merv Griffin's house
don't Murph good you guys were in Merv
Griffin summer Griffin
Delphis [ __ ] let's be real again that
brother yes if I'd been I'm like do you
guys realize what we are called up trust
me ma'am alarm armored Griffin's house
Babylon was with every five minutes like
we spoke about wait a minute see like he
gala he kept giving us like reality
check guys wait a minute do you know
that we are at Merv Griffin's house
lightly chamber I love it but yeah I was
uh I was pretty high and so I was I
wasn't handling being a empty party very
well those words it was very good and if
we were what's the first at the bar yeah
and it was people it is people started
coming in but they it was kind
stiff well Drake's dad got there early
damn right Papa please look cool she's
like hello mr. Drake I'm smoking weed
amaing man is my friend Hannibal's Tony
it seem like we're all like the old
buddies yes yeah high school together
that [ __ ] was head to toe in
white linen I would have been trying to
get pregnant
my boss he look like a boss even though
he owned the [ __ ] and after you
know what he had a legitimate thick
black daddy mustache yeah that's what I
like about her he has a nice big plan
like a nice young asian asian girl on
his arm like he look like he was killing
it Ovid and I could end it and if he had
a hazing Crockett I'm gonna it was just
it was just stiff though well even once
people started coming in it was light it
was still stiff like I was Tiffany I was
here no he said that is bad money say
kid news here man you haven't all these
[ __ ] answered didn't have people that
they're dancin you'll get Drake off that
DJ booth man I wanna have all the
[ __ ] man I love it
let me paint like what happened though
like so there's a little stage as DJ
that's no let's get out of that right so
any of you guys know Drake I had would
have once really yeah I did this event
in Houston with a a couple years ago
they brought me down the speak at
bumbie's of it but they had an event
during Houston free she Asian week
celebrating bum beat and Drake's people
reached out hey we want you to just do a
quick speech they flew me down it was uh
yeah it was weird because I was like I
knew I know bun be but net I'm like an
old friend of bumpy I read him a few
times and we've done a couple events
together but like net waka speak on him
and you know he's a man of integrity it
was there for me was what the whole time
he
been a cool nice doom that we've been
very cool in kind of a entertainment
buddy's way now but but I you know he's
good people but yeah I did a quick
speech like other people's a prince was
wanted to speak really it was April a
few other people jay printz me the mayor
of Houston oh he could well above be and
yet so I did that and then um yeah it
was uh it was interested I've been
around them at some party sometimes uh
where are we talking to some girls and
then it takes me Drake I believe no no
no no no drink comes up I'm like yeah
you know this guy this guy's
entertaining is a funny guy
it's a cool guy he's gonna have you
laughing all night and then this walks
away and then the girls like so
something hey all right uh so uh yeah
and I just Bala
so if you ever see me standing like
Drake and like having a conversation
with him I would like for you to do that
for me they like you know this girl she
this woman right here yeah she's
hilarious you know how you laughing all
night that's a mess and giggling would
you live over drink yeah and I heart
would you have him as your boyfriend I
mean it would depend after you know the
first four or five days hey Dan I have
to go I think I got a woman would date
Drake I would have to go on a few dates
with him you know see what this kissing
game is like if there's any real
chemistry in there you will make out
with him definitely oh yeah I kiss yeah
especially if I'm getting paid for it
like if we did a movie together um oh my
god we I'm just looking at any universe
right now I think we do a curse for that
yeah you got your movies on that I'm up
for like two more movies seriously Oh
okay laughs the girl trip you gone
you're gonna be this everyday gonna call
your shots trips going to come here I
mean scriptment coming to the crib
already and I was rented and I read in
and like a lot of them I like and a lot
of them like a lot of them want me to
appendix yeah yeah
what's the you have you ever found that
I did just insulting mmm-hmm yeah
mmm-hmm
like um you know that top five movie
yeah Chris Rock motorist Rock mmm-hmm so
I auditioned for the road at Gabrielle
Union ended up getting right yes and
then they said we giving it to Gabrielle
Union we have another part in here that
we think you would be perfect for and as
I wouldn't like the to one of the two
girls that have a threesome with Chris
Rock and instead you're gonna train to
come in and like bus all in the girls
faces and stuff yeah you have to be
nudists and all that I was like are you
doing this I don't remember T hi it's a
pretty long long right this big uh
somehow no one no no I'm not gonna live
like Cedric is cool and everything but I
didn't want my career to be like oh
that's a girl yeah imitative net
interface like you can yeah you can't
come back yeah I let nobody come in my
face in real life so I'm definitely yeah
are you serious
mmm-hmm look at my skin I have come in
my hand and then I rub it in my face
oh thank me that's like good hating on
somebody that's like spitting in my face
yeah I don't come on girls faces either
I think it's disrespect me too and also
I don't want to I will come on your face
and then it dribble like oh man
yeah loser respect but you will take it
in my hand and I apply to the cream yeah
yeah put it on my elbows my [ __ ] my
knees hmm
oh yeah I heard this I don't use shoes
on Venezuela she was like no semen is
good for skin semen is good for skin it
is I that's not true I don't I don't see
it is it's full of like all the
electrolyte that's mean that was true
every guy would have the softest hands
ever
there's a lot of guys with hands with a
favorite stem bladers and picking up
every [ __ ] them it's a little rough
not once right oh I know a lot of
comedians would softer hands
oh no committee recover my jaggon off
too much I think yeah we do
we got get some other stuff to talk
about but it's just so related
everyone's out there everybody does it
everybody drives off everybody takes
[ __ ] everybody going to airplane
everybody wife I don't know all
airplanes hmm where's the new special
come out the very first week of August
it'll be on Showtime the very first week
of office summertime yes Tiffany gonna
have summertime yeah Showtime is Tiffany
Haddish
she ready from Hollywood it's a
Hollywood up so in between movies you
still out there working out your
material and stuff too yep I gotta watch
your days coming up and like Boston and
stuff yes what's your favorite city to
do shows in Los Angeles outside of this
okay so outside of LA I love to go to
Baltimore I like going to Texas I love
going to Texas Chicago and that's
Baltimore versus DC you know what I've
never done stand-up in DC you mm-hmm but
I will be this year September's yeah
Baltimore's more real DC is uptight and
people's are nerds I don't know I did a
play in DC and everybody wanted like one
of my autograph afterwards which I
thought was crazy and then we went to a
strip club and it was great a DC strip
club what are you talking about DC turns
up I know but like strip clubs I never
it was taking off yeah yeah and I got
the record recreational weed thing no -
yeah I've not only got that Oh Brian
Babylon no no I it was like six or seven
years ago I was there with some two
famous guys and both of them married so
they wanted me to distribute the money
to the girls or whatever and like go get
the girls and bring them over and then
they dance or whatever in front of them
but they wouldn't touch the girls and
then maybe like to give her someone to
give us money so I'll give them some
money and give myself some money
yeah yeah that's called a swing fee yeah
it's called mission yeah
no school and I bring her I bring him
bring her bring her
let's go wrangling fee have you ever
done one those like my little Tyler
Perry plays I'll place a stop yeah I did
what my husband doesn't know David eat
Albert play and then I did a Tyler Perry
series called if loving you is wrong I
got to work with Tyler Perry was that on
the road mhm it was a it's a TV series
that's on right now yeah I did a season
way I was telling Hannibal last night
about one of my favorite shows but he'd
even know why I was called green leaf
you watch that yes it was so good yeah
why - don't
oh it is really good if what is what's
good about us it's about a black to the
church it's mostly black I think I do
like a lion has been doing we're not
anymore
what is it like I do man it's my go-to I
love it
I haven't I came up with an idea a
couple weeks ago after seeing this sham
preacher like it is deposition where
he's obviously lying put a dollar amount
on that haven't you Oh sometimes I've
given up yes I've told them that over
the years I have given a large sum of
money to this ministry okay so what sum
of money do you say when you said in
dollar amount I'm talking about a
sacrifice you put a dollar amount I know
but it is a dollar in my head and tell
me what dollar amount you use when you
tell 400 millions I've given up millions
for this given in fact for us or only in
sacrifice in sacrifice millions yes how
do you write a good figure well I mean
from the opportunities I've had to do
other things and that kind of thing that
would have paid you over a million that
will take a million ways more than real
is of course what about a black preacher
with a mega church that secretly an
atheist like this fool pimpin yeah wait
this one's been going out a lot of
pictures like no but all right
Aria hustle yes also but nobody's really
done a story or a movie about it what
are you talking about the ones got my
animals we just don't know what about my
so-called police officers aren't there
already common realize that's already in
real life I'm agreeing with you
yeah how would you know that he secretly
ACS oh when he thought that it okay open
the same boom in the middle of a big
sermon mm-hmm the crap out of 2,000
people in there holy ghost didn't [ __ ]
I'll praise the Lord Oh everything is
going speaking of John speaking in
tongues I thought oh lord bless you
touch my father's more heads hello hello
he's sweating and [ __ ] got the flash
suit on the cries jamming the band's Jam
it and the sermon ends and then he walks
off and moment of silence a stupid my
focus hold it boo boo God the other
demon dog is saying he's got a demon
voice yes oh that's a pretty desperate
that hits a demon inside of him I can
I'm on it in a human form yeah yeah if
you know they stitch okay so they say
you can be demonized I've been watching
videos about that too yes and a demon
can live inside of you
demons are real and they say that they
can live inside of you and they make you
desire things like alcohol drugs all of
that has like you don't want to have sex
with this person but next thing you know
you having sex with them and it's not
really you it don't say like if you dare
what little meet Dave or day from Eddie
Murphy that was like a alien you know
you got you know Byron Bowers it so yeah
he actually told me cuz we were hanging
out once we saw this dude walk by but he
had like the girl walk down walk a
straight legged girl he's like a man in
the South she's like back in the day
they say that a guy like that was
possessed by a female demon a female try
to rule again and they pray over you and
try to get it out and I'll be watching
on YouTube people get baby get taking
these demons out of people and stuff
these exorcism sessions ooh it is crazy
and I got so into it I went to this one
church where they do deliverances of
what they call it as a deliverance and
this lady she came in just as regular
and as normal just like a regular chick
or whatever and then the preacher start
praying and then she started like moving
different and stuff and he was like yeah
a witch inside of you and she was like
just like I met oh I don't believe I was
doing an ad I was going a bit but he
started like moving our hands and like
doing our hands like this like she plays
like you got dark see she's throwing
darts at you guys you guys got to pull
the darts I'll pull out the dark Tiffani
you have a dart in your back and I was
like for real and I just look like this
just do what everybody else was doing
but I'm pretty sure she's me her eyes
changed color
what a lot one of my homies mom's was a
super religious and she would make him
listen to exorcism tapes mm-hmm like
every time it was bad but listen is the
devil inside of you and then you just
hear just like on tape on tapes about
what is headed do you think that Dean is
what are you saying like that of the
Hollywood I think Hollywood
I think demons on set yeah I think I
think Realty was like
[ __ ] about the sound like how y'all
a kind of betraying us like yeah oh I
don't know I mean they said you could
have like the Jezebel spirit inside of
you the the whistle and Windham
manipulated manipulative spirit of
control and fear like all the different
some of these animals right but I'm
telling you when it when it's whole
thing was over the lady was like
completely different but she could have
been a biomass actress and you know all
beneath there I got $20 yeah then you
could entertain
I was definitely entertaining I do a
character study at the same time I
really want to see your computer I
wanted to see your YouTube just a
suggested video because we started going
off of what you watch so it's all just
spells and witchcraft season water girl
strip trailer the first the first thing
that come up is water fasting the
amazing effects on the immune system
yeah and then how to read anyone
instantly psychosis the next one is easy
to grow because I got a garden going if
I got plants in the trunk of my car
right now watching this garden sleep
engineering improve your life I'm
multiplying just sleep Carl June what
are the artists architects so that's
about the mandala yeah whatever anyways
distri entre the truth about English
phonics a TED talk about fasting with
this one one cup of this will empty your
bowels whoa well Justin I want that
causes a secret of vibrations and
frequencies Lee Brown 15-minute
motivational morning speech okay pay
attention your cells are listening to
how you talk to your body you can help
it more about growing stuff so a lot of
Folio yeah how does your cancer
waste zero time
[Music]
you use abuse abuse in the nightclub you
use them to this abuse of nice clothes
you give them use of you tonight
plus you give them your views of UCS at
night plus we want to rock you that
bathtub we'll look for that fact out
whether you want to rock that bathtub
you work for us what will that bath
power one word you feel so beautiful you
see if the night plus you get the
beautiful juiciest of nice what you can
forgive you of your sin it's a nine
o'clock you hear the music of UCS of
night
[Music]
Bobbo
[Music]
so this episode of the handsome Rambler
is brought to you by five for club
looking good doesn't need to cost a
fortune at 5-4 club is revolutionizing
the way men shop each month they send
you a curated box or two to three items
that are hand-picked to match the
current season and your individual style
they've been helping men with fashion
for over 15 years and shipped over a
hundred thousand men every month five
four Club will help you build your
wardrobe one months at a time
you get 120 dollars worth of clothes for
just $60 a month you could pause or
cancel anytime if you don't like that
[ __ ] there's no commitment so head to
five for club calm and enter promo code
Rambler and they'll give you 50% off
your first month's package plus a free
pair of sunglasses that's 50% off your
first package at 5:00 for club you got
to spell it out it's fi ve fo you are
club calm and the promo code is Rambler
and you get that 50% off so go to 5-4
club.com promo code Rambler what's the
last book you read the last book I read
I believe in that if a Naya Rivera book
sorry I'm not sorry who was now you I
know the name she big shot yes you date
a big time yeah I'm sorry my Revere for
just associating you with that first but
blame gossip media but not talking about
your accomplice what am i doing that
book before that that I finished reading
is a blink blink did you knock um yeah
Malcolm Gladwell yeah yes which one is
that what is the subsequent in that how
you need to go to your first instinct on
stuff is usually the right way or
anything after that that's probably a
Dean no no anything Malcolm Gladwell
is good reading though you have to read
any of his other stuff not just oh you
got to get into the tipping point the
tipping point with that
that one that one goes into like how
trends start and how like things go
viral
mm-hmm and so there's so many different
little while so like how I started
calling myself a unicorn and all of a
sudden start there's a bite yo [ __ ] yeah
everywhere is like unicorns everywhere
and then somebody was telling me there's
a zero York best-selling like unicorn
there's a trend so you're the you're the
start you were doing that even doing it
before people with all my years at least
five or six years so they even more than
that so they would call you the Maven
you're the one that started the trend
and then you have connectors that's how
no Chomsky Brown started calling me a
dirty-ass unicorn in third grade
oh and about to talk about sounds he's
from black street Wow whoa talk about
early you know I'm here don't know he
likes you probably did you ain't gonna
put a dumb unicorn no here's like look
at Tiffany cheer Dodie a dream corn
coming here smells like onions and she
that's not far from how I communicate
with women now I lighten it up a little
bit but yeah everything nothing nice
means I'd be mean to me yeah that's
where that's maturity and then we were
playing kickball one day and I have rent
you know how you get to the home base
and in like he was like the person that
supposed to catch the ball right there
instead of catching a ball he don't just
grab me and throw me over show time I'm
gonna beat yo ass in the alley and then
I bet him in a butt and then he was nice
to me ever since after that oh wait a
minute he think he just was like oh
that's rejection he was into you like
that like caveman's now he just snatched
me up throw me over his shoulder what in
a bunch o [ __ ] over the days whoa
dang dang where's uh he in life now yeah
I need no idea I hope I ain't you read
us go through we'll wait the box is
getting sha sha sha shanked is when you
get stabbed right I don't know Shawshank
is anything our movie Aladdin granted I
just call that go6
I'm shining I thought that's when you
stand so you got as millionaire on the
on the water bottle and you succeed and
then gonna succeed more as an actress
and comedian what else are you got on
what else do you wanna do once you get
your heart footing in in the
entertainment game I know you got some
other [ __ ] yeah yes I want to buy a
piece of property every year for the
next 15 years yes
so by the time 15 years come up I'll be
a multi-millionaire just off and land
alone okay and then also I would like to
one day you know open up some group
homes for disadvantaged youth and have
like arts and stuff going on like for
foster kids because a lot of times when
you in a system there's no there's you
you move from school to school so much
you have no chance to really invest in
your art so I would like to provide a
platform for that and then I wanted to I
mean I'm already investing them in
marijuana that's on the stock market and
so tell me about that because I just I
just saw something about that just we
stocks it's very new ultimately it's
like eight companies right now Luis
Guzman tell me about it the actor and
here's like Tiffany Manning you got
money you want to put that [ __ ] in we
eat it's going to get a new it's like
it's like back wooden tobacco got hot
you know yeah put it in weed so there's
and he was telling me that the different
companies there's a science there's two
science ones what I do Studies on
marijuana and that's Alex I want to have
put some money in on them and there's
growing companies and distribution I'll
tell everybody the secret part out
I see on the end of the bike and I went
to my computer
Tasos and look at these stocks right I'm
gonna invest in here too so I hear ya
hair I want to start like a hearing loss
she ready hairline we've purchased I'm
sorry expense extensions hair products
you know hair care stuff and then a
clothing line to in really close mmm-hmm
there you go
got that yeah she ready he ready we
ready clothes me they we ready is a
unisex fence is it gonna be better than
a dairy on house of deréon uh also but I
would like it I don't know about fashion
that much but that those clothes weren't
that dope or am i right or wrong you're
right I mean it's some other things I
guess so do you ever old Rocawear ya
know ya know you never hold a piece of
Rocawear I don't think so I have some
Rocawear Jean 150 yeah I mean I was I
was with I was dressing too preppy for
that Rocawear I have Rocawear sweatpants
and I love them shits mm-hmm I just got
rid of my rocket wear jeans because my
booty got too big I can't clothes on
number one but they so dope on the
ankles is all painted like cities
nothing like the Rhino and yeah I fell
for a Rocawear well I didn't I wasn't
like head-to-toe Rocawear buy a couple
pieces yeah you always always see guys
in the hood who you can tell they just
go to jail cuz they dress like Pelle
Pelle Pelle Pelle or where or I got
multiple cutters overall music my mama's
house when I got out but who's like what
they had you got that big-ass telly
jelly leather pellet go with the
rhinestones how does a good shape
kidding maybe 150 Oh like you've been
away for like eight nine years then head
back it was looking great as a yellow
season three Carmichael self yes season
3 of the Carmichael show however
it's been great it's a it's pretty funny
I'm pretty excited about it because
we're talking about some crazy stuff
like we got an episode of by stripping
we got an episode a triple ambition yeah
we got an episode about with it when you
kill yourself suicide
you can't exist the suicide yeah yeah
yeah that Kevorkian stuff yeah kind of
something like that awful episode about
not a mental illness that was on it
every season there's a lot of stuff it's
a great show by the way thank ya you you
guys you guys all have amazing chemistry
of the show thank you we get insight in
word on NBC total six pounds no say
nigut oh and now on one episode whoa I
wish I just got it I would think they'll
give you like six in words for the
season mm-hmm it's a menage tois episode
mom got three someone mmm three screws
three screws reason Episode four
Jarrah's character no for reals care
click the right dancer what a rail got a
episode about rate Oh II think you might
erase my mise au pair the show getting
real like not real yeah he not sure if
he breaks somebody in that photos but
how like what is rape
yeah okay yeah you guys tackle some some
touchy subjects it's a good you know I
guess my question is when you guys are
on set just hanging out is the chemistry
as good as I mean it just seems like
y'all are just real tight we are it's
like a family we hang out together
I felt like Loretta Devine is my my real
mom like maybe she was supposed to have
me but she had an abortion instead and I
ended up with my crazy mama but I ended
up with my real mama anyways yeah yeah
that's how I feel about her she's
alekseevna with man she a legend yeah
yeah she's been in the game was the
first thing you remember singing our
dream girl she was in the original stage
dream girls and I remember I was like
four or five years old my mom says you
know remember seeing him her
was Lucia david alan grier was in
Dreamgirls what's her name gotta play a
lady they played a Moishe mama on Moishe
whoa digging deep oh you're talking
about
Oh guys
she's like Moishe members but she was in
it Oh guess what John guess what I
didn't got my own ass
Oh if you go if you go to the Apple
store and putting Tiffany Haddish yeah
my app pops up I didn't even know I had
a app I just was like y'know thing of
North Korea and somebody made me a ax
really yeah don't like show a lot of
stuff that I like on YouTube things that
I posted on Twitter and stuff my show
days they got my show dates in there
yeah and you could buy tickets to my
show through the app I just joined my
own app well I don't even know how to
control it I got different he had a
shout yeah it's crazy
whoa okay I gotta act like I knew what
it was
you name last until you shot a picture
but you know right that's a pretty girl
you are the epitome of like Cali girl
like when I come here visit my cousins I
will always like like a girl who look
like you like man Kelly got girls man
well you know how we got girls we do do
we didn't we cute you want one I could
hook you up definitely excellent
wingwoman the best I am really good at
that that's likes to hang around that
the my guys out of time even you I
stopped trying to holler at me they
wouldn't holler at me they're like if go
get go get her number for me oh just get
her to come over here like all through
high school junior high that was my job
yeah yeah I was a go-getter
just a wingman now you take it as a
challenge yeah yeah I mean I'm gonna
good at it so if you just be like oh I
like her I'd be like you do okay
and you can think that and you
tell like go with your time team you can
like yeah I could tell right away I by
the way a woman's band I can feel like
no octopus all she really thirsty ah no
oh that [ __ ] got herpes you might not
want to do that can you do it you can
tell I mean cute Oh somebody has a
flare-up or they have it in their system
I mean that's a good question that is a
good question
I mean I would I I hear that it's only
contagious when there's a flare-up you
suggesting that I will give it our peace
that makes me wish that now that's that
is decided to do this has to be a video
podcast why where's Neela streaming on
filming because Tony's is was at the bat
in the bathroom for about a minute and
just sat down so far too tough of hurts
whenever whatever I forget rid of me you
know
this year there's a cure for it what for
like rich people for like all people
don't care for her what vinegar hot
spicy vinegar
exorcism it's always very good memory
although you know they say a not
cilantro but cilantro helps oh I'm sorry
cilantro is a earth it's a herb and like
the yellow is cilantro if we're come on
tacos and we're ready okay amen they say
uh what's that oil not olive oil
condiments so this color blackk like
oregano oil oregano oil is that with
olive oil like you get the oregano oil
extract you mix that with olive oil and
then if you have an outbreak you put
that on the outbreak but they say if you
get the oregano oil and you mix it with
olive oil and you like put it on your
lower back
yeah
and around your mouth I guess if you
have it run your mouth whatever your
lower back in your spine is we supposed
to put it because that's where her feet
high
Oh Annie I was having your back herpy
pies in your cells in your spine there's
metal and everybody's body especially
like what's going on in environment so
most of those metals are stored in your
spine so heartbeat hides in like where
the metals are which is in your spine
harpy's hides in the spies hard this is
hard to the spa - hide in the spine put
that olive oil on it you don't want to
have parents and it itches and it's not
good for you and if you have the boon
nobody will love you you want to kill it
you want to kill it
care to her do you the her food you want
to stop tiemuzhen eat greens that's the
blood you want to make sure that you
[ __ ] least two times a day you wanna
kill it kill it
get a healthy but you gotta live with it
for the rest of your life you change
your diet and you eat it right yo yo
buddy
Ann stop stop [ __ ] people wrong thank
you don't fund row and we give a
shout-out to our sponsor metal trick
valchek's a common animals free magic
spins camera back on public low example
hilarious funny I got I got a building
in the crib in Chicago and the people
who live on my third play moved out and
getting people leave stuff they don't
take everything so I'm in the bathroom
and we clean the stuff out and this lady
had left few bottles just yet some
valtrex in there mmm my paws like the
gif it always keeps giving the father
better father LP you trying to got hurt
oh man herpes we heard a lot of people
getting a lot STD man ever I already got
STDs because they just doing 70s [ __ ]
don't ya
old-timey sees the last always yeah you
want raw back then ain't unchanging when
you get older right so I'm gonna keep it
wrong I was gonna do them and saw like
old timey condoms I was like how was he
even gettin time like it was like
seriously a brown paper bag
I mean it kind of was so horrible like
the little scary monsters I don't know
like condos in like World War one that
was the lambskin those condoms back then
thank me kind of since they're 1800 be
said I didn't know that I thought those
started in the 90s there was a lot more
people a season one the real world to
maybe have commented hilarious
yes so I learned about all that stuff
from looking at this doctor CDs because
I was trying to do a cleanse and then
they was talking about herpes and
stuffing and I fell into the rabbit hole
[Music]
and that's actually a lower intestines
poisoning me I would like to take I
would like to take a couple of weeks off
and just cleanse out mm-hmm you've been
amazed at what like having fish on
charge
did you know that Vicks VapoRub gets rid
of a pimple within 24 hours and it helps
get rid of cellulite and it makes your
skin like super [ __ ] by no point I
know that I'm dropping jewels on these
are all the stuff you rub on your chest
yes the [ __ ] you rub on your chest if
you like if you got cellulite on your
thighs or whatever you read that on your
thighs it'll tighten it at the drop
it's like it's extrinsic I think you
call it where it draws out like so you
find like our girl we got girls pool
party crying pool ready grim get this
vapor run yeah I do it that's a vapor
rub and I do it all the freaking time
like if I gotta wear shorts for
something I'm like the night before I in
vicks vapor rub in my thighs like
[ __ ] because i'm skinny-fat yeah
and then the morning of i'm fixed like
for revenue and I walk anything like
doing smell like sex rehab like yeah but
then people say you put you can put
Preparation H under your bags in your
eyes and it gets rid of that Giga tight
you can only do it for so long if you do
it every day it makes the layer of skin
fin and then you get the dark cycling
you can see the veins and stuff your
eyeballs fall out whether your eyeballs
look like silently
you'd be better off putting like
cucumber under there or my cold spoon
mmm
all right let's close it up let's close
it out yeah I switch mics a combo girl
trip and she ready yet okay girl trip is
out what day so I'll turn on fire to
delight 21st she ready out what day
August the week after July 21st oh [ __ ]
that's gonna be a crazy couple of weeks
right
alright you ready to do this she bought
him Tiffany Haddish
girl trip she ready kill trip see
[Music]
girl in the movie in the movie never get
ah ah yes
Tiffany Haddish you and it yeah and then
can I can I can I do one more thing yeah
yeah do you think she is ready from the
hood to Hollywood she is very something
that's a Hollywood she is ready from the
hood to Hollywood sure it's very from
the hood to Hollywood my check was for
said my pencils ready perfidy anis thank
you so much for coming
[Music]
you